hi guys scifi recapped here
before we start warning
spoilers ahead today i'm gonna explain a
2018 american psychological horror movie
called cam
the movie begins with a young girl alice
who live streams herself as a cam girl
on a paid platform called free girls
live
she uses an alias lola and is working
hard from her home studio to attract
viewers so that her rank on the platform
can jump to the top 50. a viewer
encourages her to use a knife and slit
her own throat sparking debates in the
comment section
however she enthusiastically takes a
knife and slits her throat spilling
blood all around then turns off her live
stream
turns out it is just a prank but the
attention she got was enough to get her
to the 53rd rank after the successful
stream she privately video calls two of
her loyal fans dumpty humper or tinker
and barnacle bob who always tip her
generously
they played an important role in staging
her show earlier encouraging her to use
the knife she explains her desire to get
to the number one position which is
currently held by a user called barbie
girl
through text she plans a date with
tinker her younger brother jordan whose
birthday is approaching knows about her
job but their mother does not
jordan has long been pushing her to
reveal the truth to her mother but she
plans to do it when she reaches the top
10 to be considered good at her job
alice then goes shopping for jordan's
party supplies meeting her friend katie
at the supermarket she also notices a
man resembling tinker but he quickly
gets out of the store
before her next live stream in the
evening alice calls another fellow cam
girl fox brainstorming ideas for her
show so that her ranks could advance
further up during the call alice's rank
drops to 55 making her more eager to do
more attractive shows
she then video calls barney learning
that they can meet next week as he is
coming to her town
she schedules her appointment with him
on her calendar
starting her live stream she celebrates
as she finally reaches the top 50.
however after a while viewers stop
tipping her and her ranking drops tinker
tries to call her but she ignores it she
learns from one of her viewers comments
that another cam girl princess x is
encouraging everyone to leave lola's
stream and drops her rank by 10 to get
her naked alice ends her stream and
angrily watches princess stream but
fortunately her rank only drops down by
nine
tinker calls her again from an unknown
number saying he has got a job is
currently staying in the area and did
not mean to stalk her earlier
still enraged by princess action alice
goes to the camgrill clubhouse to
perform a joint session with fox as she
had suggested earlier meeting princess
at the club alice confronts her but she
does not seem annoyed luckily the stream
with fox successfully increases her rank
to 47.
waking up the next day alice gets
difficulty signing into her fgl account
her access is blocked but through
another account she notices that her
account is online and live streaming she
suspects fgl is replaying her old
streams so she calls fgl's tech support
however they seem to not take her case
seriously she tries to attract her
doppelganger's attention through the
comment section to prove that the stream
is not her old replayed videos and that
works
getting more puzzled she tells the
incident to her fellow cam girls
she suspects princess and fox might have
something to do with it as her account
was hijacked after she streamed at the
clubhouse
however they say there is no reason for
them to hijack her tinker having the
real name arnold goes to her house to
give flowers
he thinks lola is inviting him to come
to her house and meet her mom but alice
refuses she explains that the one
talking to him last night is not herself
and kicks him out of the house
she then tries registering for an fgl
account again only to find it
unsuccessful as her id has already been
registered her impostor goes live again
this time performing erotic acts in a
library the stream is viewed by many of
jordan's friends at his birthday party
making them laugh behind alice's back
as alice and jordan's mom invites
everyone to gather so that jordan can
blow out his candles a fight ensues
between jordan and his friends as they
have ridiculed his sister alice's mom
takes a phone from one of his friends
thus discovering her daughter's real job
embarrassed and out of words alice
storms out of the party
alice continues watching her
doppelgangers live stream
she is now performing sadistic acts
spanking and hitting herself as her
viewers demand
the viewers get more and more wild so
she produces a gun and motions to shoot
herself
after a while she really shoots herself
in the mouth driving alice to a panic
attack
she tries to call fox but to no avail so
she goes to the police to report her
impersonation case
sadly the policeman looked down on her
not taking her case seriously to make
things worse one of them asks irrelevant
questions regarding her job which he
thinks are compliments instead of
insults angry alice leaves her
doppelganger announces a joint stream
with baby girl so alice tries to
communicate with baby girl by going to
her stream and attracting her attention
through the live chat however she
notices the phrase start my fire not put
it out said by baby and remembers it
being said somewhere after digging
through her doppelganger's old streams
she found that her imposter had said the
exact same words in her first stream she
calls fox again asking for baby's real
name but she laughs as she thought alice
is doing a joint stream with baby
tomorrow
showing up to her date with barney at
his hotel alice learns that barney is
also baby girl's loyal viewer thus
helping her get to the first rank
she cleverly asks questions to gain
information about baby from him
she learns that baby lives in georgia so
she excuses herself to the bathroom to
further browse the information
at the same time the fake lola goes live
alerting barney that the person he is
meeting with is trying to impersonate
lola and scam him he goes impatient and
storms into the bathroom to get alice
luckily she escapes
she further learns about baby girl's
real name hannah darren who is actually
a dead person since a car crash took her
life six months prior
that means baby is a fake as well
meanwhile the fake lola and baby's joint
live stream is played in the background
the fake stream shows that the home
studio setup is absolutely the same as
hers they even go to her bedroom and the
fake lola shows a photograph of jordan
alice panics at the side of it screaming
thinking that the doppelgangers are in
her house
however the live stream transition gets
blurry sometimes like a glitch or bad
rendering she goes home to find her
mother's attitude softens toward her she
even praises her for her performance on
fgl
however jordan refuses to talk to her
she then conducts more extensive
searches on other cam girls who have
collaborated with baby girl in the last
six months there are several girls and
all of them have one in common one of
their top fans is tinker alice goes to a
motel where tinker or arnold is staying
crying when he finds her then assures
her that he is going to help her solve
the problem he even allows her to stay
in the motel with him concerned for her
safety
sometime later when she wakes up from a
nap she discovers arnold in a private
video call with a fake lola
enraged she drags him out and demands
answers even hurting him with her taser
he confesses that he knows about the
doppelgangers which are probably ai
software and that there seems to be a
pattern to which the girl will the
doppelgangers attack next however he
insists he is not involved in it alice
faces tinker's camera now face to face
with her fake to which she asks whether
she is tinker's girlfriend and is
seemingly ignorant about how she
resembles alice
frustrated alice makes her way out of
his room despite arnold begging her to
stay
alice goes back to her home studio and
sets up the vanity mirror to make
multiple reflections of herself then
demands a private cam session with her
doppelganger she accepts it then alice
asks again that their private session be
broadcasted live
the fake lola agrees then the audience
goes wild as there are two lolas alice
challenges her fake to play monkey c
monkey do in which the winner will be
determined by the viewers and gets to
pick a prize the game is simple they
challenge each other to imitate what
they just did and let the viewers judge
in the first round the fake lola wins so
she demands alice to strip
as the game goes on alice gets the idea
to say her exact feelings to her viewers
that she has been locked out of her
account and a doppelganger has taken her
place
she ends her statement by hitting her
own nose against the table breaking and
bleeding it her fake follows but a
glitch is clearly seen on screen a few
moments before the blood shows up
proving her suspicion that the fake is
an ai the viewers cheer on alice this
time so she wins this round as a prize
she asks for lola's account password
although confused at first the fake then
agrees to give it especially after being
pressured by the viewers
finally gaining back her access alice
disables her account just as she reached
the first rank on fgl sometime later
alice helped by her mom gets ready to
perform again this time under a legit
new identity that she even has a fake id
with
she registers a new fgl account with
that id and goes with the username eve
bot
she says that she will be doing this
again and again even if the ai continues
to find a hacker
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching